riddled with continuity errors and plot
holes and plagued by the notorious cgi
removal of a super stash the theatrical
release of justice league was a huge
disappointment for many fans
however the snyder curt has finally been
able to fix a long list of mistakes
errors and unanswered questions from the
joss whedon version of the movie
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining the top 17 dc plot
holes and problems fixed in zack
snyder's justice league of course
spoilers ahead so take care
the theatrical release of justice league
was vague and short on details about the
mother boxes and why they'd only awoken
after superman's death even worse the
weed and reshoots
ended up contradicting the timeline
established in batman v superman for the
experiment that silas stone performed on
victor
because in the theatrical release silas
didn't get hold of the mother box until
just after superman's death
it was shelved till the night superman
died then she lit up like christmas
they brought it to star labs where my
father recognized it as a perpetual
energy matrix this is inconsistent with
bvs where wonder woman saw
footage of victor's transformation into
cyborg with the mother box before the
battle with doomsday and death of
superman
the snyder cut instead remains faithful
to the original timeline and establishes
that well before superman died
silas stone found a way to harness the
energy from the mother box
victor's father activated a mother box
more than a year ago
superman was still alive didn't call out
to steppenwolf none of the boxes did not
until
not until superman died it's like they
were afraid of him that line
also explains that it was very
specifically superman's death and the
powerful anguish death cries of the
kryptonian which we see in the opening
scene
of the snyder cut that awakened the
mother boxes to send a message out to
apocalypse as diana later explains to
bruce
something woke the box my people guard
it called out to the dark place
to one of darkseid's conquerors
something introduced
during whedon's reshoots on justice
league was the idea that parademons can
sniff out fear
batman used a criminal sphere as bait to
catch a parademon at the beginning of
the movie
and steppenwolf mentions it when he's
threatening the hostages from star labs
the stench of your fear is making my
soldiers hungry
this creates a plot hole though because
at that moment the justice league are
hiding just outside the room where the
hostages are being held and flash
reveals that he is petrified
i'm afraid of bugs and um guns
and obnoxiously tall people which begs
the question why didn't the parademons
sense barry allen's fear and discover
him
on top of that inconsistency this fear
concept is used in the final battle
against steppenwolf when he becomes
suddenly afraid of the justice league
after superman and wonder woman destroy
his axe
this cannot be recognized
this ends up being a rather
disappointing way for the movies big bad
to go out
especially in comparison to the final
battle in the snyder cut which is much
more epic
with superman first slicing off one of
the villains horns and then the team
killing him and sending him through the
boom tube to land at darkseid's feet
thankfully the whole paradigm and fear
subplot and resultant plot hole have
been completely removed from the snyder
cut
and instead the only significant mention
of fear is this badass moment
after steppenwolf arrives in the
amazonian stronghold
i will bathe in your fear daughters of
them show him your fear
we have no bear a cryptic moment from
bruce wayne's nightmare that's never
been fully explained is when future
flash arrives to give batman a message
in the weed and reshoots it seemed it
was partially explained when batman
arranged with alfred to bring in lois
lane as a backup in case superman's
resurrection went wrong
diana was right about the risk if the
plan goes south we're gonna bring in the
big guns although in both versions of
justice league it's lois who arrived
just in time to calm superman down
in the snyder cut this has nothing to do
with batman lois is simply making her
final visit to superman's memorial by
herself
in fact snyder has said that the flash's
warning from the future about lois lane
is referring to something much
bigger and several scenes in the snyder
cut elaborate on what he's hinting at
barry allen was right here and he said
to me lois lane is the key
she is to superman i think it's
something more
something darker we know from cyborg's
premonition that lois will
die and the epilogue scene between
batman and joker
also reveals that batman was somehow at
fault for her death which led superman
to go to the dark side
you need me to help you undo this world
you created by letting her
die the snyder cut also includes an
interesting additional scene with lois
where we see she has a pregnancy test in
her bedside drawer which she then picks
up and goes to use in the bathroom
following on with the baby theme there's
a notable difference in the snyder cut
in the final scene at the clark family
homestead where lois is carrying a baby
basket into the house
rather than the removal box seen in the
weed and cut snyder in fact has said
that lois's pregnancy is something the
studio had asked to be removed before he
stopped work on the movie in 2017.
a debatable plot hole that some fans
have noticed from the weeding cut of the
gotham harbour tunnel scene is that it
shouldn't
be possible for the flash to move people
around safely at super speed when they
aren't wearing a protective suit like
him
the snyder cut resolves this issue
specifically by not having flash move
anyone around in the tunnels and instead
he simply zips back and forth
showing people where to go and later on
he uses his super speed to rapidly move
a stack of rubble that's about to fall
onto the hostages when they get out of
the tunnels
the dangers of the speed force are also
clearly shown in the snydercut scene
where barry allen's shoes disintegrate
as he turns in them at super speed when
he goes to rescue iris west
it goes without saying that snyder's
justice league restores henry cavill's
stashless superman scenes doing away
with the dreadful opening sequence from
the weeden cut
where the avengers director seems so
desperate to be acknowledged for his
hard work on the film that he included
this sign
but more importantly fans finally got to
see superman in his iconic black
suit from the death of superman comic
book storyline which had been teased
before the theatrical release but was
never delivered
the snyder cut also connects to and
elaborates properly on the nightmare
scene from batman v superman part of a
much larger storyline and something
which was essentially ignored in the
theatrical cut of justice league leaving
fans wondering what the point of it had
been
the snyder cut on the other hand begins
to answer some of our questions about
that enigmatic dream from bvs
the first revelation comes in the
premonition of the future that cyborg
sees just before superman is resurrected
in the kryptonian ship
in that vision we see a dark future of a
dead wonder woman with dark side
arriving to conquer themyscira
the death of aquaman at the hands of the
dark god and a grieving superman holding
the charred remains of lois lane as he's
about to be brainwashed and taken over
by darkseid the snyder curt's epilogue
also continues bruce wayne's dreams of a
post-apocalyptic future as we see the
dark knight forced to work with his
enemies deathstroke and the joker
this scene is also interesting because
for many fans it's a marked improvement
on jared leto's joker that we saw in
suicide squad
the tattoos on his head which were
generally disliked have gone or at least
covered up and this scene now confirms
his involvement in the death of robin
which was alluded to in batman v
superman by the graffiti costume in the
bat cave
why you sent a boy wonder to do a man's
job
this scene which snyder added in reshoot
specifically for this cut
is also a nod to his idea for a batman
and joker film
something the director has admitted is
unlikely to happen now
a character who got completely
short-changed in the theatrical version
of justice league was cyborg
it seems he was the main character who
suffered from the crazy studio mandate
that the movie had to be a maximum of
two
hours long which seems especially
ridiculous given that in the wedding cut
screen time was given over to adding a
random russian family in order to
supposedly make the conflict more
relatable to ordinary people
in the theatrical version cyborg wasn't
an especially interesting character and
his backstory was extremely
underdeveloped with just a few slight
references to the accident in which he
lost his mother
and the reason that his father
experimented on him in fact ray fisher
has even said that almost
every single scene of him in the
theatrical cut was from the weed and
reshoots
the snyder cut thankfully revolutionizes
our view of cyborg putting him as zack
snyder himself
said at the heart of the story we get to
see victor stone's kindness
his troubled relationship with his
father him learning to use his powers
and becoming a crucial part of the team
from fixing batman's flying fox to
confronting his own insecurities in
order to defeat the mother boxes
on top of that watching his own father
sacrifice himself in order to place a
tracker on the third mother box
is a particularly emotional moment and
adds another layer to the character
in sharp contrast to the wedon version
where silas stone is still alive at the
end of the movie
another character who gets more
development in the snyder cut is barry
allen with this version setting up the
flash's upcoming movie much better
barry saved the world when he reversed
time allowing cyborg and superman to
separate the boxes before they formed
the unity
we also saw him reverse time briefly
during the superman resurrection scene
when he didn't quite reach the mother
box in time to charge it initially
this ability in the snyder cut together
with the first mention of the multiverse
in the dcu movie so far
and the joker discussing alternate
timelines with batman in the epilogue
set the stage for the flashpoint movie
in a much more satisfying way than the
theatrical version did
and although barry is still the comic
relief among the group in both versions
of the film
gone are some of the worst parts of
whedon's reshoots such as barry drawing
on a prison visitor's face the tedious
brunch jokes and of course the moment
where he falls on top of wonder woman
a tiresome joke that whedon obviously
finds so hilarious that he recycled it
from avengers age of ultron
we also lost several other cringe-worthy
weeden editions such as martha telling
lois lane that clark said she was the
thirstiest girl he ever met
and aquaman calling wonder woman
gorgeous while under the influence of
the lasso of truth
and there's an interesting little fix to
the scene where the justice league break
into star labs
in the theatrical release the date of
birth of barry's fake military profile
is november 2010 which at the time of
the film's release 2017 would have made
the character only seven years old
in the snyder cut the date's been fixed
so the birth year is now 1997.
also much improved and fixed in snyder's
justice league are the villains
steppenwolf's design has been vastly
upgraded together with his backstory and
motivation for collecting the mother
boxes
it was a really intriguing added detail
for his armour to change with his mood
and even retract entirely when he
prostrates himself in front of darkseid
steffenwolf is still a big cgi villain
in both versions but his character is
much better
developed in the snyder cut which makes
the final battle with him and the way
the justice league defeat him much more
satisfying than in the theatrical
version
but on top of that the snyder cut also
properly reveals the real big bad of the
movie
and of the snyder verse as a whole
darkseid who was referred to but never
properly explained in the weeden cut
in the snyder cut darkseid also replaced
steppenwolf during the extended and much
more satisfying flashback to the
invasion of earth when the amazons
atlanteans gods green lanterns and men
successfully resisted and repelled the
villain and his minions
something that puzzled many fans at the
end of the theatrical release of justice
league is how lex luthor managed to
escape from arkham asylum
the snyder cut doesn't fully explain
this but does give a hint in the much
longer epilogue scene with luther and
deathstroke on the boat
i heard you're a few clowns short of a
circus i was thank you
until the good doctors at arkham helped
me find some much
needed clarity this clown reference may
hint that the joker was involved in
luther's prison break and the mention of
doctors here might also suggest that
luther bribed some of the staff at the
facility
to send over a bald lookalike into his
cell while he escaped
another unanswered question from the
theatrical cut some fans have wondered
about is how aquaman knew about the
atlantean mother box
the snyder cuts restoration of a deleted
scene between arthur and volkow helps
clear this up
the snatchers have come from the dark
place they're looking for it
the mother box our people god is not
safe go to the stronghold of atlantis
likewise for wonder woman the inclusion
of a deleted scene where diana visits
the shrine of the amazons
explains how she learned about
darkseid's previous invasion of earth
the snyder cut isn't entirely faultless
of course and there are a few
inconsistencies that this version of the
film seems to have introduced in
particular how it relates to the aquaman
movie
for example mira has a very strange
british accent which is completely as
odds was the american accent she had in
the weeden cut and the aquaman film
where the legends say atlanta's trident
was forged
he's as short-sighted as he is cruel and
then there's the way that aquaman tosses
his shirts into the ocean and smashes
whiskey bottles by the shore
but complains about rubbish being thrown
into the sea in his own movie
now did you spot any other problems that
the snyder cut fixes or any new plot
holes in this version of the movie
comment below and if you enjoyed this
video do leave a thumbs up
tap here to check out some more videos
you might like including the deleted
alternate ending
and cut scenes for the boys season 2.
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers